with dark and an end and yes I'm still
crying about it I thought it would be
fun to rank who had the worst fate why
because I'm crazy now I had a really
tough time with these selections almost
everyone on this show has a pretty [ __ ]
life but there is definitely someone who
takes the cake as worst fate but before
we begin make sure to LIKE and subscribe
and do check out my other two dark
videos I did one on the complete dark
series timeline as well as season 3
ending explain and you can find links to
those in the description below also if
my rankings are different than yours
just know that you are wrong and I'm a
hundred percent correct but be sure to
leave a comment posting where you drank
your favorites in the comments below
but onward to number 10 Katerina Neilson
not only does Katerina lose her son
Mikkel in the very first episode of the
series she also has to contend with a
cheating husband for most of season one
she's completely depressed staying in
her home and forgetting about how her
other children are feeling then near the
end of season one her husband Ulrich
goes missing as well
Katerina just can't seem to catch a
break until about season 3 when she
actually manages to find Ulrich in the
80s and vows to break him out of the
psych ward she holds her mother at
knifepoint in an attempt to get a key
card to the ward but ends up getting
killed by her now have you think that's
bad this is only number 10 number 9
Claudia Tiedemann now some of you may be
shocked at this being so high up the
list and there's a reason for that which
I'll get into claudia has her own fair
share of [ __ ] like accidentally killing
her father taking over a nuclear plant
hiding barrels of toxic waste getting
killed by noah watching her daughter
slowly die of cancer and spending years
in the post apocalypse trying to get the
god particle to work you may be asking
yourself how is she not lower on the
list and the reason I didn't put it
there was that Claudia is the only
person in the show who has some control
over her destiny everyone else is a
puppet to fate but Claudia actually
orchestrates the events that will
actually lead to the not being destroyed
she actually gets what she wants in the
end a world where her daughter can live
without pain that's why I put her higher
up even though some of the stuff that's
happened to her may not technically be
as bad as
things that happen to characters lower
on the list number 8 peter doppler peter
is an interesting case because we don't
get a lot of personal time with him but
he is a character who suffers from
immense emotional pain much of which is
caused by the repression of his
sexuality and how that affects him in
his family in season 1 we learned he had
an affair with a transsexual woman named
Benny and that he's basically staying
with Charlotte just to keep the family
together
he can't be who he really is because he
believes it would jeopardize his family
then there's also alternate world Peter
who is a priest and there's this weird
scene where Charlotte finds him with a
young man in the church and it's heavily
intimated that he's having some sort of
relationship with him in the future
Peter believes he's lost his wife and
daughter Francesca and goes everyday to
the blast zone
to see if he can find them he's then
stabbed to death after trying to save
his daughter from being sexually
assaulted number 7 elizabeth doppler
from father now to daughter elizabeth
not only had to deal with the
dysfunctionality of her family before
the apocalypse but no one is even
talking about how she lost her boyfriend
Yassen remember Yassen that boy in
season one who is captured by Helga like
Peter Elizabeth had to deal the thought
of her mother and sister being dead and
is sexually assaulted by a vagrant watch
as her father died his hands before
beating the assailant to death with the
fire extinguisher she'll later fall in
love with Noah and have a child
Charlotte who is stolen from her she'll
later find out that Charlotte was sent
back in time in his her actual mother
talked about [ __ ] up number 6
bartosh Tiedemann bartosh was dealt a
pretty shitty hand before the apocalypse
he finds out his girlfriend is actually
in love with Jonas and then when he's
sent back in time at the end of season 2
he spends decades in the late 1800s and
early 1900s completely stuck he also had
to deal with the fact his mother Regina
was dying of cancer in the 1800s he'll
fall in love with soulja who gives birth
to Noah and she will die a few years
later giving birth to Agnes following
Adams orders he spends much of his time
digging out the passage with his son
Noah only to be killed by him after
losing faith in Adams plan lots of
family members killing family members in
this show number 5 Regina Tiedemann
Regina's life was so bad that Claudia
spends 3
seasons going back and forth in time
just to prevent it from being so shitty
as a child Regina was a loner who is
picked on by the other kids like Ulrich
and Katarina
she even self-harmed in the earlier
seasons we see her mother is extremely
controlling of her something Claudia
later regrets and tries to change as a
child she's also wrongfully accused by
Ulrich and Katarina of being the one who
went to the police and alleged that
Katarina was sexually assaulted by
Ulrich when in fact it was Hannah her
hotel business is a failure she doesn't
know who her father is
and in both timelines she dies a slow
painful death to breast cancer not to
mention in one of them she's suffocated
to death by taranta who she believes may
be her father her husband is also a
criminal on the run from authorities
taking up an alias and her last name to
better protect himself number four Helga
doppler do you like killing multiple
children well Helga is your man even
though he thought these killings were
for the greater good you can see in the
show how much it affects him at one
point he even tries to tell Noah that he
can't do it anymore and that's one of
the things that made me put him higher
up on the list the show often questions
what hell is is it a place where you go
when you die where there's endless pain
and suffering or is it here on earth
living with the pain and suffering of
your past misdeeds I happen to think the
latter the amount of pain he has to live
with is unbearable and his older self
eventually goes back in time in an
attempt to kill him as a child Helga had
an extremely overbearing mother who is
so cold it left me with the sense she
didn't love him and to top it off he's
friendzone his entire life by Claudia
Hill later almost died at the hands of
Ulrich who believes by killing him it
will prevent his own son from going
missing but he survives and is left with
this side of his face and ear being
disfigured he spends most of his adult
life as a janitor at the nuclear plant
and his later t-boned by his future self
who has traveled back in time to stop
him he survives this and will later get
dementia number three Ulrich Nielsen
Ulrich is another example of someone
living their own personal hell which I
would argue in some instances is a fate
even worse than death as a teen he has
to deal with the disappearance of his
brother Mads and her mother going crazy
as a result of it not
and how his father was cheating on her
he's even falsely accused of sexually
assaulting Katarina but those charges
are later dropped he also just has
terrible taste in music as an adult he
cheats on his wife in both timelines all
add and ends up attempting to murder
Helga a small child believing it will
save his son he'll later end up arrested
and when Hannah comes to visit him after
traveling to the 50s he's betrayed by
her and left to rot in the psych ward
things get much worse for Ulrich in the
80s 30-plus years after being arrested
mind you when he finds out that his son
is actually alive in that time he plans
an escape does end up seeing him but as
later caught only to be found by his
wife a few months later Katarina plans
to get him out but on the night of this
escape she doesn't show up
Ulrich doesn't know she's been killed
but will spend the rest of his days
completely alone in a psych ward never
getting to see his family ever again
completely alone number 2 Hannah Tauber
aka Noah it's the guy we love to hate in
those earlier seasons but I kind of
warmed up to him in the later seasons
knowing how much he was betrayed and
manipulated by those around him
beginning with young Noah he had a rough
upbringing growing up in the early 1900s
and watching his mother died giving
birth his manipulation by Adam started
at a young age and is so entrenched in
him that he does Adam's bidding of
killing his own father bartosh hill
later orchestrate the killings of
multiple children believing that these
deaths are all for the greater purpose
of fulfilling Adams plan of paradise
not only does Noah do all these terrible
things he later realizes he was being
manipulated by Adam and is killed by his
own sister Noah also has to go through
the hell of living in the post
apocalypse where he'll later have a
child with Elizabeth only to have that
child stolen he'll end up killing
Claudia his great-grandmother where he
learns from the missing triquetra pages
that his missing daughter is in fact
Charlotte so basically imagine you've
done all these terrible things and you
believe you're justifying and doing them
but you find out it's all a crock of
[ __ ] and you've actually been hate
terrible person this whole time oh and
you lose your daughter
that's what Noah had to go through and
finally we have our number one I think
we all know who
is going to be Jonas Kahn Walt when I
was planning out this video his name
wasn't the one that automatically came
to mind for having the worst fate but
when I started doing my research he's
just leaps and bounds beyond anyone else
and I'll explain starting with younger
Jana see he has to deal with the fact
his father committed suicide in season
two we learned that suicide was because
of yonis not in a bad way but mornin I
need to kill myself so my son can follow
his path to save the world kind of way
so yonus feels a bit responsible for
that when yonas comes back to school
after the summer of his father's death
he finds out the girl he likes is dating
his best friend and in season two he
learns that he will eventually become
the person he hates most Adam after
surviving the apocalypse he tries to
kill himself but he can't even do that
fate will not allow him to kill himself
as long as his older self is still alive
so Yunus ends up spending decades
trapped in both the post-apocalyptic
world and the 1800s as he slowly morphs
into Adam his continued use of traveling
through time leaves him horribly
disfigured and he adopts the philosophy
that he must destroy the knot so that he
and the others can go to paradise a
place where there is no pain or
suffering and he does terrible things in
this quest like ordering Noah to kill
children killing his own mother as well
as Marta his one true love who carries
his child
in fact he spends most of his time
fighting the person he loves most Eve
aka Marta like Noah Adam will later find
out he was being manipulated but in this
case by Claudia all those terrible
things he did only perpetuated the loop
they didn't destroy it his years of
planning were in vain his senseless
killings unjustified for these reasons
yonus is number one on my list so that's
it for my top 10 worst baits in dark and
what are your rankings make sure to
leave a comment below and like and
subscribe while you're here I also want
to mention my two other dark videos a
season 3 ending explained in my entire
series timeline you can also follow me
on twitter at thing story YT until next
time remember daddy loves you very much